In 1998, the French National Team called "Les Bleus" won the World Cup.
A moment that was celebrated throughout the country.
And it seemed to be a breakthrough for French multiculturalism as well,...
...since several players were either immigrants themselves...
...or children of immigrants who came to France in the 20th century.
The team was called the "Black, Blanc, Beur", meaning "Black, White, Arab",...
...a spin on the three colors of the French flag.
Since 2002, the number of Parisian-born players at the World Cup...
...has continued to rise.
Out of all French players at the 2018 World Cup,...
...16 were born or raised in Greater Paris.
And the French national team has eight.
That includes Kylian Mbappe, France's 19-year-old superstar...
...who was born to an Algerian mother and Cameroonian father...
...in the Parisian suburb of Bondy...
...and was trained to the French system Clairefontaine.
But Parisian players don't just play for France.
Over the years, FIFA's eligibility rules have allowed them...
...to play for countries like the Ivory Coast, Morocco, Algeria,...
...Portugal, Cameroon and Togo.
The combination of an established academy system...
...and its unique immigration history is producing incredible talent...
...for France and the rest of the world.